Speaker 1: We have a new report about these anti
vaccines offering fake vaccination cards. And an
anti vaccine influencer has now been charged
with selling fake vaccine cards. This is being
reported in Rolling Stone article by E.J. Dixon.
Fifteen people, including Jasmine Clifford, a.k.a.
Anti Vax Mama, have been charged as part of an
alleged conspiracy to sell fake vaccine cards.
A New Jersey woman who went by the
handle and tiebacks mama on Instagram
has been charged with helping to run a business
to distribute fake covid vaccination cards,
according to a press release from the New
York State District Attorney's Office. Jasmine
Clifford, 31 years old, the self-described
entrepreneur from Lyndhurst, New Jersey,
very entrepreneurial, is accused of selling
approximately two hundred and fifty fake covid
vaccination cards on Instagram, charging
two hundred dollars per cart. She's also
isn't that that's 50 grand, right? She's also
charged with falsely entering at least ten
people into New York State vaccine database for
an additional two hundred and fifty dollars data,
which was transferred to New York State's
official Excelsior Pass system. Clifford, who
has more than three, had more than three hundred
thousand followers on her main account. Five star
Jazy is facing charges of criminal possession
of a forged instrument in the second degree,
offering a false instrument for filing in the
first degree and conspiracy in the fifth degree.
An alleged coconspirators conspirator and Nadette
in the days of Berkeley, twenty seven years old,
is facing similar charges, allegedly for using
her position as a medical clinic clinic worker in
Patchogue, New York. Or is it Patchogue to enter
names into the New York State vaccine database?
According to a video by Tick Tock
participant who exposed Clifford last week,
Clifford was notorious for spreading
anti back sentiment on multiple accounts,
while her previous Antibalas account, ActiveX
Mama, had been removed by Instagram earlier
this summer. She had already accumulated
more than ten thousand followers on her
backup account and tiebacks mama to D.M. for
religious exemption letters she would post.
She also believed mandatory vaccinations were part
of the LGBTQ agenda. Oh, so also also homophobic,
I guess. Consider how clueless you must be to be
buying a fake vaccine card. What I mean by that is
it's just a simple piece of paper anybody could
make, especially since, like you might say, well,
it's on slightly thicker cardstock than
just paper. Yeah, you can go and buy that
for a few cents a sheet and then print the card
yourself. But more importantly, I mean, I'm not
trying to I'm I'm not giving advice on how to do
this. I'm showing how dumb you have to be to go
and buy the card for two hundred bucks or whatever
it is. You can just take a picture of the card and
have it on your phone. That counts in most places.
So like, why would you pay someone for it? It's
very simple. And people now the really crazy thing
is at the end of the day, the vaccine is free.
So instead of going and printing and scanning
and photographing a fake vaccine card that if
paying 200 bucks for a fake vaccine card and then
another 250 to get put in the state database,
the vaccine is free and it protects you from
covid particularly serious covid. And then your
name will be legitimately added to the New York
database for free. It's it's truly, truly stunning
that this is going on. And it doesn't bode well
for the country guys. It really doesn't bode well
for the country. But these people need to have the
book thrown at them. Now, I got an email saying,
David, is it true this person could get six years
in prison? I think that, you know, with all of
these things, if you look at the three charges
and then you look at what is the maximum possible
penalty for each of the three, and then you run
them consecutively rather than concurrently,
I think there is a theoretical framework where
this person could get six years or eight years
or something like that. It's not going to
happen now. My belief is the book really
needs to be thrown to these people. They need
to be punished seriously. They need to be made
examples out of. But I would not expect six years
or even or even three years here by any means.